we begin with very good news for one of
Nascars most beloved figures he's
recovering after dramatic escape from a
plane crash
Dale Earnhardt jr. and his family were
in a small plane that ran off of a
runway and caught fire yesterday in East
Tennessee CBS News has exclusive video
of Earnhardt being treated at the scene
he his wife and young daughter along
with the two pilots are all ok Omar
Villafranca is at the airport in
Elizabethton Tennessee near the North
Carolina border Omar it is remarkable
nobody was hurt it is good morning and
the County Sheriff says the Earnhardt's
were extremely blessed and fortunate
after everything that happened and let
me show you why take a look at what's
left of that plane we're just a few
yards away and we can still smell the
charred rubber officials say when the
Earnhardt's got off the plane it was
already on fire and as bad as the
situation was everyone survived a
witness captured these images of the
flames and plumes of smoke erupting from
the plane carrying Dale Earnhardt jr.
and his family okay everybody come
alright paramedics are seen tending to
Earnhardt after his plane ran off the
runway thursday afternoon according to
some witness statements just after it
hit the ground it started murdering
firefighters arrived on the scene within
minutes two pilots Earnhardt his wife
Amy and their one-year-old daughter ila
managed to escape the crash uninjured
first arriving unit reported flames
visible but the occupants were already
out of the plane the nose of the plane
and the door stayed intact while excess
fuel continued to burn the Cessna 680
business jet was built in 2015 where the
flames coming to an area where they
would've been sitting I'm sure they were
yes
forty-four-year-old Earnhardt is a
third-generation racecar driver known as
jr. his charisma and success behind the
wheel earned him the title of NASCAR's
most popular driver 15 times he retired
in 2017 and now works as a sports
analyst the family is no stranger to
tragedy
Earnhardt's father Dale senior died in a
crash on the final lap of the 2001
Daytona 500 he was on his way to an
event in Bristol Tennessee at the time
of the crash officials say the plane hit
a fence that wrapped around the aircraft
but did not block the door leading out I
guess the only word I could say is that
they were extremely lucky Jr has had
plenty of crashes on the track but
really nothing like this and this hits
close to home because in 2004 his racing
teammate Ricky Hendrick died in a plane
crash at near Martinsville which is less
than 200 miles away from where we are
right now federal investigators are on
the way over here to find out exactly
what happened in this accident
Tony we're glad everyone's okay Omar
thank you very much